now a new study showing the cheapest
state to start a new business is right
here in Nevada thank you for joining us
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian
Loftus Ryan Matthey delved into the
numbers today he joins us now live from
Desert Inn and Eastern an area with many
small businesses with what's making
Nevada Ryan so affordable
yeah Brian Kirsten the U.S Census Bureau
reported in just February alone 430
000 new businesses Across the Nation
thousands of them chose to set up shop
here in Nevada and according to this
study entrepreneurs here have certain
incentives they just can't find in
another state I've had people in here
every day like do you have new
squishmallows when are you getting new
ones Sydney Edwards and her husband lost
their jobs in early 2020 how they made
ends meet doordash Uber GrubHub things
like that pumpkin day yeah but in
February they took a leap opening Divine
fines in Centennial hills it's like a
mini Target so everything's like 25 to
75 percent off the retail price and even
with family and business prospects in
Utah they chose Nevada to get your
business license you know to get all
your tax stuff done with the state of
Nevada it's actually pretty reasonable a
new study by small business publication
simplify LLC reports Nevada is the least
expensive state to start a new business
thanks to the average cost of running
one like salaries tax rates and monthly
utility bills these Nevada numbers are
hundreds to thousands of dollars more in
other states the study found the
regulations the requirements just opened
up shop was so much easier here in
Nevada it comes after business woes from
the pandemic but as the economy recovers
Vegas chamber chairman Paul Anderson
says incentive programs through the
state of municipality or chamber are
helping to cover other costs the Vegas
chamber was the first of its kind to
open up opportunities for retirement and
for insurance plans it's an important
piece of the puzzle those things are so
expensive for an employer to be able to
provide to their employees and so we're
hoping as we get more and more people
into those groups we can make it even
cheaper for them
[Music]
did the study also rank the states with
the highest certain viable rate for
these businesses Nevada came
reporting live near di in eastern Ryan
Matthey a news now Ryan thank you for
that Nevada is followed by Colorado and
Arkansas for cheap Estates for new
businesses Minnesota New York and
Louisiana were found to be the most
expensive States